hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play limbo okay my voice is still
a little bit raw from the 24 hour
livestream we just did which I am
incredibly grateful I'm gonna make a V
log about it pretty soon but I'm just
I'm getting my voice of rest but for now
let's continue for it oh that doesn't
look good
okay does that crow my new enemy now
gigantic crow monster probably probably
do so why are there so many dead kids
around here okay oh uh okay what missile
crickety oh wow
what what what really that killed me oh
it's 10 whole feet and I landed on a box
really that big of a deal
oh well whatever
jump over and then I jump back I guess
no oh okay I gotta wait Oh lovely why
didn't that kill me
ah man I think I was a bit my tongue
I don't know I've got a lot of things
I'm gonna complain about throughout the
entire let's play but Wow jump okay good
good alright that's that didn't kill me
really how did I die then how did I die
that's what I want
never not a big deal I got it I got it
up we go
hmm this looks dark why did that sound
like a spider what is that what are
those looks like maggots dead headless
body what am I supposed to do here
bounce off the body
Oh oh no way oh why so there are brain
maggots brain maggots and they suck out
your brain hey buddy
let's say you're trapped down there like
a big old trap ah
scratchy a button if I could pull body
out of the river cryo do it yep this
looks perfectly normal I have to [ __ ]
you I push you up the mat it's not
really mountains underground now son
about Hill there's a word for that
there's word for an underground hill or
not I push right the other guy go but in
one sees dead friend gets squished here
now brain maggots yeah little baby oh
they're eating the brain maggots all
right then
this world is freaky freaky deaky oh boo
oh hey about it are you doing that okay
Pass you said they got a bit like tongue
or something like the bottom I my tongue
is in pain and I mind I complain about
it but whatever it's another trap yeah
yeah it was it was so
jump jump perfect off flawless execution
[ __ ] dude really gotta be like that huh
you're gonna be like that you do that to
me
- really dude don't joke or do put it
kind of make that jump
yeah I can hop her Boosh yeah yeah ah
what ah
don't shoot me bro no Jimmy ha ha ha
what have you got the other ones coming
got wouldn't you guys know you guys know
about those Hot Diggity can't give me
why is everyone trying to kill each
other in here fiercely you think the
kids would well they'll the kids are
working anything seriously you think
they could start working together they
would take on any survivors where have
all these kids come from why do I have
the only eyes my spare a character have
the only eyes
on the left
this looks good
I'd pull you I pull you okay I know I no
longer fool I push you push you there's
something over there oh okay I get it
alright still don't know what this cart
is for but my money oh I get it
well I don't get oh ok so there wasn't
enough time for me to get down here
after I pulled that down nothing all
right let me try just moving forward if
I die nothing new ah
down here a nothing nothing so that's
one
what's his car duct I jump on me i bish
you there is enough time on them let me
try just getting down very quickly by
falling or something maybe there's
enough time I don't know
okay go go go go go go go go go go go go
go maybe this card is just a red herring
grab it grab it grab it damn it
there's not enough time
ah to be something about this I miss you
but what do I wish you sir why do i
Boosh
brunch okay what do I do with this cart
so obviously obviously I have to pull
that cable down and there's something I
missed I have to pull that cable down
then I have to get down to hang on it
still can I use this body no maybe if I
like to throw it in to keep bumping into
the gears to block it up I don't know
maybe I can actually get down that way I
don't know no that'll probably
crunch what to find her she was deed
let me thank you
ha ha
we'll get it give it can we get to get
to get up get it I don't know
if there's something down maybe maybe or
maybe I'm just gonna be stuck here for
ten minutes
oh no that was stupid hmm
must have something to do with this card
I'm early
now what is it this card can only go
there that does not mean anything for me
ha I can't even oh oh
maybe the reason this card is there is
that way I can if I'm quick enough I can
jump on it and then up and grab it maybe
I just got to be quick I just gotta be
quick
that's all I gotta do I gotta be quick
here we go Huck Huck Huck Huck up put
pop and then I jump and then I jump and
then I forget yup ah got it got it sweet
and then I jump straight from here swing
on over to the other one so how this is
gonna work
OOP bah hoop it did it did you then I go
and then I go then I go and then I wait
and then I go and I go I go I go yeah
I'm good hahaha I can't believe I did
that
5:25
okie-dokie oh that's a brain maggot I
see I'm looking at it to guy Oh
what wait what I can only make it go
faster in assertive action oh oh oh oh
this is part of the game oh ha ha ha job
whoosh run abyss you I miss you
no no no no no no no no you go Luther oh
maybe I need to get them to eat the
maggot I suppose you go slow
oh ah I get I was pleased to go slow so
that those things could eat it or jump
or something like that
Oh wonder what this is all about oh no
it'll jump okay let's go yeah yeah yeah
oh I need to jump over the box and then
get on the box and then jump up so that
those things can actually eat it I get
it I get I'm a genius wings
aha then jump over the box and I slow
you and then I push you
I push another jump up like a jump again
oh yeah ha ha no big deal that was all
in my brain and whatnot but whatever
whatever
ah oh my god we got over here
whoa don't be alright I'm back I don't
know what happened it just all a sudden
all tabbed on me don't know why but I'm
back hello oh what's that
it's trying to get some fudge or some
mushrooms fudge oh you're scared to me
about time something is it's credible
new cute yeah
oh wait that's not there ah come on I'll
get you some food good guy Hill Poochie
are you been sweetie
uh-huh come on out little guy we must
catch that come here [ __ ] I'll getcha
I'll getcha Oh run run perfect perfect
no oh yeah hello guys what's that this
Dutch
one eye that made it rain
what what
say hi um I'm Alan I'll figure out what
the hell that means
laters thank you all so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next bye bye